impresionantes imágenes satelitales que
muestran la magnitud de la ola invernal
que afecta a eeuu
fuertes nevadas y tormentas golpean el
noreste del país según el servicio
meteorológico nacional se espera que
caigan de 30 a 60 centímetros de nieve y
soplan ráfagas de más de 100 kilómetros
por hora
esta es una tormenta muy seria muy seria
nos hemos estado preparando para esto
esto podría poner en riesgo la vida y
queremos asegurarnos de que tomamos
todas las medidas que creemos que eran
necesarias incluso comenzando con la
declaración de emergencia
el alcalde de nueva york instó a sus
ciudadanos a no movilizarse
pero escuché hoy de monos quedémonos
'new jersey' y boston también se sumaron
al estado de emergencia sin embargo
algunos entusiastas ven con otros ojos
el fenómeno metereológico tan pronto
como vimos que hay una tormenta de nieve
o lo que sea supe que quería estar aquí
porque amo la nieve crecí en el sur no
estoy acostumbrada a la nieve así que
esto es increíble en este contexto más
de 6000 vuelos fueron suspendidos
todos los vuelos han sido cancelados hoy
pero tuvimos suerte de llegar ayer esta
es una de las tormentas más fuertes que
han azotado la zona en 1978 un fenómeno
similar paralizó el nueva inglaterra
causando la muerte a una decena de
personas y provocando el bloqueo de las
principales carreteras por una semana